so I've got a not great update on the
coinbase hack I don't want to retell the
entire story because a lot of people
have heard it several times already but
basically last week we were hacked and
several thousand dollars in
cryptocurrency that we had received for
some advertising deals a were was stolen
from our coin base account there was a
huge back-and-forth of about 6 days a
security investigation coin base has
both changed their policy about publicly
asking for support ticket numbers via
Twitter which was sort of how all of
this started if you look at the coin
base support Twitter account you'll see
they now are asking for those via direct
message they've also changed their if
you go to the page where you submit a
support ticket they haven't read a
paragraph specifically related to how
the hack against us took place so
clearly they've decided that to some
degree the old policy was a liability
because they changed it but they've also
decided quite simply that their review
of our case is over and they're not
compensating us period so we kind of
have two choices we can move on with our
lives or we can try to create a problem
for them would be difficult really to
create a problem for them we're one of
more than 20 million coin based
customers we spoke to our attorney he
said listen I can send a legal letter
but it's probably a waste of time and
money because it's not really going to
do much at this point and it's not even
clear we can create a big enough sort of
public PR problem for them to make a
difference now interestingly I decided
to research the addresses that did the
hacking of course these addresses these
cryptocurrency addresses are anonymous
in the sense that we don't know the
names of the people associated with them
or the bank accounts associated with
them but what I was able to identify was
a series of sort of shell crypto
addresses feeding into one primary
address that has received about 1
million dollars in aetherium
cryptocurrency of late so when you see
the fact that the people that stole from
us have transacted about a million
dollars in crypto recently this is not
in a sense it's not a tiny opera
raishin although compared to the massive
hacks that took place at the exchange
level mount cox and others a million
dollars is not very much but we're
talking about the theft of a few
thousand here and there adding up to a
million dollars this is many many
individual transactions and of course
statistically I'm sure many of those
were coin based users not all of them
more than likely we are not going to
have much of a choice but to move on so
we will continue growing our support
through membership through patreon and
one thing we do have going on Tom Baker
who's been a longtime supporter of the
show he got in touch over the weekend
said David I want to help in some way
with the coin base hack let me
contribute and do a sponsorship of half
of fifteen David Pakman show membership
so what tom has done is he's prepaid $30
for 15 people and what that will now
allow is 15 of you to get a half-price
membership that'll get you the bonus
show that'll get you the daily
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show first-come first-served
email in through our website david
pakman.com say hey I want one of Tom
Baker's memberships I'll send you a
coupon code and the best part of all of
this other than paying half price once
is that you can keep the half-price
membership as long as you want you can
renew at half-price indefinitely or ad
nauseam as the case may be from some of
you just get in touch say hey give me
one of those Tom Baker memberships at
half-price David